bindi irwin shares an intimate photo  cuddled up with her boyfriend  the 17 year old dancing with the stars  contestant shared a snap with boyfriend  Chandler Powell who flew to Los Angeles  to see her dance in the cute black and  white photo bindi gushed about her beau  writing thank you for always making me  laugh helping me to ice my foot when it  hurts making me tea and hugging me when  I'm tired you're amazing the daughter of  the late Steve Irwin met the  eighteen-year-old wakeboarder back in  2013 and she seems totally smitten there  is someone special in my life right now  and I'm really happy with that the  couple hasn't shared too much about the  relationship but have posted some pics  of their adventures together including  canoeing and hiking with friends